[Musique]
oui
mika qu'est ce qu'elle attend il va
bientôt se réveiller
comment se passe ton stage d'assistant
social harry est un danger pour son
entourage et pour elle même elle a
besoin d'être encadré
attendez
tu crois qu'un cheval peut changer
quelqu'un elle est pas mika et coarraze
y doucement avec le volant qu'elle
ressemble peut-être un peu mis au point
où est harry at elle déjà mangé elle
croit que je suis un cheval est toi qui
es tu je suis la cousine de sam
bienvenue à calton bar ni cas ne se
réveille pas parce que wii sports va mal
et whisper ne mange pas parce que mika
va mal nous devons trouver un remplaçant
à mika personne ne remplacera mika tu
veux manger
qui es tu toi je suis la cousine de sam
et vous le grand père de sam
les chevaux sont sensibles aux énergies
tu dois apprendre à contrôler la tienne
pourriez vous me la prend mais tu ne
pourras pas monter whisper il a perdu
beaucoup de force depuis qu'il refuse de
manger
il a mangé mes carottes
il est en danger je vaux schl ça nous
aiderait que tous les deux
le guerrier et son cheval ne font qu'un
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mikail toi vous êtes très différentes
mais ensemble vous êtes prête à tous les
combats
[Musique]